some people die in her sleep I wonder
how if I would like that
dying in my sleep uh
I almost the thing about dying in your
sleeping people don't think about this
if you die in your sleep you don't get
any last words you don't get
that last uh
serving of outspoken you don't get to
say anything
if you're stabbed or if you
you know fall down some stairs or you
know if you're stabbed you can oh you
know what
what are you stabbing me what do you
stop me
you know and then maybe some famous
quote or something you get to do you
know
uh I could have been a contender Give me
liberty give me death you know
uh from the window to the wall you know
I mean you get to at least if you were
a lot if you're out and about or if
you're
if you're not asleep if you're not dying
in your sleep you get that last moment
you know even if you're falling down
some stairs you're like
oh dang this is the last time I'm gonna
be
what the [__]
yeah but at least you get to you get a
final say
what do you think you do rally Mao would
you die in your sleep or would you
you want to go out in a living moment
I think I want to go out in a living
moment
and what what would you have a final
word or something would you get a
you get one final jab in it the world of
verbal
Jab
uh
yeah I don't know I would say uh
you know
something alrighty we'll come back to
you Brad you thought about the thing
what would you say if you're dying
Raleigh
uh I've not
okay do you have it has anything kind of
come to your head that was you know your
last words
um not that I could think of
all right we'll come back to you in a
little bit what would your last words be
Riley to you
did you get something
I'll just say you know I mean if I can't
uh
if it is my last words and I can't you
know
have more words I'll just be like I'm
out y'all peace
okay
there you go even if it's a slaying
you're at a park somebody stabs you you
know
I mean I can't go back in time if they
already stabbed me and I'm already dying
you know why not go out with Bing
yeah I'm out guys peace
yeah I like that kind of it just kind of
covers everything kind of
no matter where you're at it's kind of
okay it's not really like abrasive to
anyone
just like I'm out
right yeah my last words I'm trying to
think would be uh
uh let me think somebody stab your
shoots you
and I'll be like
gang gang
or maybe I'll be like [__] better have
my money
one of those man I would hit him with
that gang gang or [__] better have my
money
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one